en france deux jours avant la nouvelle
grande journée de mobilisation nationale
si les perturbations à la sncf et à la
ratp sont désormais quasi nuls d'autres
secteurs restent très mobilisés contre
la réforme des retraites plusieurs
actions coup de poing sont menées sur le
territoire notamment contre la cfdt des
actions revendiquées par la cgt signe
que les relations se tendent entre les
syndicats ont fait le point avec
grégoire douce et la fracture semble
consommé ce lundi une nouvelle intrusion
a eu lieu au siège de la cfdt
d'après la confédération une quinzaine
d'individus encagoulés sont venus couper
l'électricité durant quelques minutes
une action revendiquée par des syndicats
cgt énergie d'île de france
berger négocié les couleurs et les
formes de nos futures chaînes et celle
de nos enfants sans jamais avoir
participé à la grève reconductible
contre la retraite à points
cet incident intervient après une
première intrusion vendredi dernier
qualifiée de violente par laurent berger
le patron de la cfdt
quelques dizaines d'individus se sont
introduits violemment dans les locaux de
la confédération cfdt ce midi ils ont
agressé verbalement et physiquement des
salariés de la cfdt
nous condamnons cet acte et nous ne nous
laisserons pas intimider
la cfdt cible des critiques de plusieurs
syndicats depuis qu'elle a accepté le
compromis proposé par l'exécutif sur la
controversée réforme des retraites
une plainte a été déposée par
l'organisation réformiste qui a
également publié un communiqué
la cfdt poursuivra son combat pour plus
de justice sociale et de solidarité
entre les travailleurs sans jamais se
laisser dicter ses positions par des
actes de violence ou d'intimidation
de son côté le secrétaire général de la
cgt philippe martinez a tenu à condamner
ces actions nous condamnons toute forme
de violence
mais pour être très clair il y en a
marre du cgt bashing nous n'avons pas à
porter le chapeau de tout ce qui se
passe dans le pays dès qu'il ya un
problème on cible les militants de la
cgt alors que le projet de réforme des
retraites est toujours au coeur des
débats
le climat entre les syndicats se
refroidit nettement sur fond d'intense
divergence est les syndicats qui
entendent maintenir la pression sur le
gouvernement alors que vendredi sera
présenté le projet de loi en conseil des
ministres la fédération cgt commerce
appelle ans hier à une journée nationale
de grève et de mobilisation aujourd'hui
un parti 200 lazare une manifestation
s'est déroulée ce matin direction opéra
ou retrouve notre reporter na li de
khalifa el david le cortège vient donc
tout juste d'arriver à destination
effectivement à sophie le cortège s'est
posté juste devant l'opéra garnier une
manifestation qui s'est passé dans le
calme en entouré par les forces de
l'ordre quelques fumigènes ont craqué
les manifestants qui venaient de toute
la france pour exprimer leur colère
vis-à-vis de cette réforme des retraites
et surtout signifier que cette réforme
ne concerne pas seulement le secteur
public mais aussi le secteur privé ait
des manifestants issus de la grande
moyenne ou petite et distribution venir
ici à paris était important pour eux
afin de maintenir cette pression sur le
gouvernement deux jours seulement avant
cette grande mobilisation prévue pour le
retrait pur et simple du projet de loi
de réforme de retraite est aussi
évidemment la présentation de ce projet
de loi de réforme je vous propose
d'écouter la voix a marre secrétaire
général de la fédération commerce et
distribution on à la veille du dépôt
au conseil des ministres du projet de
loi on veu râpé remet qu'on laisse aller
aussi dit qu'au marché des services aux
croûtes ce projet même si le
gouvernement essayait de faire croire
que ça concerne qu'une catégorie des
cheminots la ratp on la choisit aussi
pour montrer notre solidarité envers nos
camarades cheminots qui ont mené la
bataille des flambeaux mais pour nous il
ya la seule négociation sur leur train
et drop allait réellement des solutions
avec l'eau le régime actuel si je prends
un secteur que je connais très bien ce
que l'heure du commerce
80% de femmes travaillent dans le
secteur du commerce 75% c'est du temps
partiels imposés score partiel imposé
nouzaret dans le commerce a commencé une
caissière à 600 700 euros par mon
infinie à 1100 euros
alors moi j'habite madame chez palal la
mise qui dépendent toutes les causes des
pannes voulions nous expliquer quel est
la retraite d'une salariée du secteur du
commerce dans l'avenir personnes en
capacité de nous apporter cette réponse
non c'est très bien si on prend le
projet c'est à dire on prend toute la
carrière
on va se retrouver encore les dindons de
la farce désolé de fart cette expression
mais ce seront eux les salariés du
commerce et des services qui vont perdre
dans cette réforme
l'objectif était également de montrer où
elle avait entendu en les conditions
précaires de du commerce a en tout cas
de la grande distribution des employés
de la grande distribution la
manifestation s'est donc achevée ici
devant l'opéra garnier et lé
manifestants sont plus motivés que
jamais à deux jours de la grande
mobilisation nationale
l'objectif est toujours le même
également évidemment le retrait pur et
simple du projet loi de réforme sur les
retraites
[Musique]